avec nous avec nous léo ferré qui est un
téléspectateur attentif comme claude
lelouch mais pour d'autres raisons quand
ils habitent en italie regardante n 2
c'est vrai que vous recevez bien notre
chaîne aurait bien dans votre lettre
peut-être qu'aujourd'hui les forêts que
le temps donc vous suivez pas
parfaitement tout ce qui se passe en
france et je sais que tous ces choses là
vous intéresse alors si vous êtes ici
aujourd'hui parce que les éditions de
grésivaudan c'est une petite maison
d'édition dar qui se nichent assez
signer c'est près de grenoble commence
la publication des poésies complètes de
léo ferré
vous allez voir cela c'est cet imposant
et c'est important ça constitue donc un
deux trois volumes georges illustré de
56 photographies du peintre jacques un
chèque n'a alors c'est un tirage limitée
à 300 exemplaires
mais pour les bourses moins garnie où il
y aura à partir de janvier la même chose
mais en cinq petits volumes très bien
alors léo ferré a choisi de donner
attira tout cela vous dit poésie au
pluriel et pas chanson ou sur ce tour
bus course par fc la chanson c'est la
poésie mise en musique dit pour moi oui
mais c'est pas une volonté délibérée de
mettre à l'écart le mot chansons que
vous ne trouvez pas trop digne de
l'alléger mis à l'écart de toutes les
les chansons j'ai j'ai écrite et que
j'avais fait éditer pour des besoins
fameux j'ai besoin d'argent contre les
éditeurs et il parle s'il sait que les
éditeurs sont les jambes aux minables
celui en général en général avant et dit
ils sont obligés d abominables même avec
les gens aimables comme vous oublie pas
oui peut-être mais les éditeurs il
fallait vous savez c'est terrible ça
dépend où je veux dire à vous avez
essayé ça non vous pouvez bouger vos
invités
moi je mets goût faudel prononce à venir
le hibou du couchage
je suis l'éditeur le a gelé geek je
dirais que si ça n'est pas édité chez un
autre c'est moi qui gardait les droits
vous comprenez zitter il a vu comment
ils travaillent maintenant mais alors
éditeur et où prennent le truc
et puis ils vous prennent la moitié
détruit des droits du disque et le tiers
des droits à la sacem tenir le terrain
des droits d'exécution et le 50% des
droits du disque ils ne font
rien quand je dis rien cryengine2 fric
mais ça ça vous a toujours frapper je
vous ai souvent entendu parler de ce
discours entre ce qui sort de vos têtes
et ce qui atterrit chez le client se
dresse à vous a toujours j'ai liquidé
intermédiaire oui les intermédiaires
mais les intermédiaires comme ça oui
c'est terrible
dans le dise ces faits autrement quand
même nom mais cette fois-ci vous êtes
contents les eaux avec cette édition
j'espère vous ce que vous n'y a pas de
problème je sais pas me les les chansons
et poésies dit chanson est dit est
d'accord alors je vais vous à rencontrer
votre illustrateur jacques hainard est
votre éditeur en plein travail
alors ça va nous donner l'occasion et
bien de feuilleter votre oeuvre et
d'écouter la chanson préférée de
patricia acharnée elle n'est pas la
seule
ça s'appelle avec le temps nous si nous
n'aimons bien
avec le temps venu
sans eau
quant à eux
où chercher
c'est tout
femmes dont seulement
220 le saunier
6e
non
avec le temps
pas juste référé pour pas illustré
ferrer faut faut faire un climat à côté
de serre et qui ressemble qui est de la
tripe avec ferrer et puis cette espèce
d'orgue avec le temps
tous sont m
mais toujours sourire s'intalle dessus
à la galerie choix
dans les régions de la moins
samedi soir
quand la tendresse qui
ça représente ça représente plusieurs
années de préparation déjà elle
travaille depuis pour faire le livre
puisque tu chez nous tout est plié à la
main assemblé à la main ils ont fait
représente la manipulation de 100 tonnes
de papier le pliage de 3 2 millions 600
mille feuilles et environs payer un peu
plus de 1000 km à faire à pied autour de
la table pour faire l'assemblage au
client c'est essentiellement d'élus
biofilm ça donne un petit peu de tout
dans nos clients vous avez des personnes
qui vont acheter léo ferré parce qu'elle
aime léo ferré qui achèteront jamais
d'autres livres maintenant à leogane
clientèle de bibliophiles qui fait
automatiquement chaque année quand on
sort un livre à chaque année où chaque
deux ans quand on fait un livre l'achète
automatiquement
ils ont confiance en nous qu'on sort de
la qualité
ça
on se sentait trahi
car on vous voit de temps en temps à la
télévision c'est de se dire mais qu'est
ce qu'il fait y ait dans sa maison là
bas en italie fait l'éditeur il fait
l'imprimeur mais non mais vous êtes sur
les routes très sonore on voit rarement
à télévision un cv ça vraiment je viens
télévision quand on me demandait que
c'est possible pour moi ouais y'a des
fois le jour à on a téléphoné pour me
demander d'aller chanter une chanson à
l'extérieur là oui ça s'appelle comme ça
elle confie c'est plus une même
propriétaire c'est plus humain
propriétaires ont téléphoné pour les
chanter une chanson pour un type que je
connais que j'aime bien ton pire pour
lui faire plaisir et je dis pas vraiment
du chanteur pas juger vous savez que on
me demandait là bas pour gmail
comment ça marche quoi je n'ose pas
demander de l'argent mais il ya le
voyage comme ça oui
abonné à l'oeil oui pour le maçon l'a1
ouais c'est peut-être un bon maçon mais
alors il restera en il est peut-être pas
au courant est jeune et il sait pas qui
je suis mais sûrement pas mais ici c'est
qu'ils nous ce type là le maçon et on
vous êtes appuyé nous on vous invitez
mais on aurait pu se dire que ceux qui
aiment entendre son préféré quand même
un peu folle et ce soir il était au
théâtre de sartrouville
il y est aussi demain et après demain et
puis continue sa tournée très bien merci
de votre visite raciste et deux que je
vais jouer avec sympathie et revenez
nous voir on voulait c'est pas pouvait
retrouver
si vous avez quelque chose à nous
proposer ou pas pour dire bonjour pour
dire ce que vous voulez un vélo